نعتقد أن الحواسيب الكمية ستسمح لنا بحل بعض المسائل أسرع مما نستطيع بالحواسيب الكلاسيكية وحدها لكن
فهم كيف يحدث ذلك أمر دقيق اليوم في Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي سنحاول الكشف عن مصدر قوة
الحوسبة الكمية من خلال النظر في واحدة من أوائل
الخوارزميات مرحباً بكم في Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي في هذه السلسلة سنستخدم Qiskit لاستكشاف بعض المفاهيم الأساسية
التي تُغطى عادةً في المقررات المتعلقة بالحوسبة الكمية كل فيديو مصحوب بوحدة تفاعلية
مرتبطة في الوصف أدناه فتأكدوا من الاطلاع عليها إذا سمعتم كثيراً عن الحواسيب الكمية فقد
سمعتم على الأرجح أنها تستطيع استخدام ظواهر كمية مثل التراكب والتشابك والتداخل لحل
المسائل بطرق لا تستطيعها الحواسيب الكلاسيكية لكن كيف بالضبط تساعد هذه الميزات في عام 1985 كان David Deutsch
أول من أظهر كيف يمكن أن يحدث هذا توصل إلى ما يُسمى الآن خوارزمية Deutsch التي تستطيع حل
مسألة بكفاءة أكبر مما تستطيع خوارزمية كلاسيكية اليوم سنلقي نظرة على خوارزمية Deutsch
وتوسيع لاحق يُسمى خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa ونفحص كيف يمكن استخدام الجوانب الكمية الفريدة للـ qubit
لصالح الحواسيب الكمية ثم سنشغل هذه الخوارزميات على حاسوب كمي حقيقي مع Qiskit
هناك خوارزميات كمية أخرى تُظهر أيضاً ميزة نظرية على الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية المعروفة وليس كلها تعمل
بنفس المبادئ التي سنراها اليوم فما سنتعلمه اليوم لا يشرح بشكل عام كيف يعمل الحاسوب
الكمي لكنه يساعدنا على البدء في رؤية كيف يمكن الجمع بين مبادئ ميكانيكا الكم لصنع
حاسوب كمي قوي قبل الغوص في خوارزمية Deutsch لنفكر أولاً في كيف تختلف الحواسيب الكمية
عن الحواسيب الكلاسيكية وكيف قد يمنحنا ذلك ميزة في حل مسائل
معينة أحد الاختلافات هو أن البتات الكمية المسماة qubit يمكن أن تكون في حالات تراكب بدلاً من
الاقتصار على حالة الصفر أو حالة الواحد كما هو الحال مع البت الكلاسيكي الـ qubit
يمكن أن يكون في حالة تراكب من كل من الصفر والواحد نكتب هذه الحالة
هكذا حيث a و b أعداد عقدية مجموع مربعاتهما يساوي واحداً وكلما زاد عدد
الـ qubit زادت هذه الفجوة بتان كلاسيكيان لا يزالان في واحدة فقط من هذه
الحالات الأربع الممكنة 00 أو 01 أو 10 أو 1
1 اثنان من الـ qubit يمكن أن يكونا في تراكب لجميع الحالات الأربع المسموحة كلاسيكياً وهو
يُكتب هكذا بشكل عام نظام كلاسيكي من n بت لا يمكن أن يكون إلا في واحدة فقط من 2 أس n مجموعة
ممكنة من الأصفار والواحدات نظام كمي من n من الـ qubit يمكن أن يكون في تراكب لجميع 2 أس n من هذه
الحالات التناسب أسّي فحتى لو كان لدينا 10 qubit فقط يمكن أن تكون
في حالة تراكب من 2 أس 10 أي 1024 مجموعة ممكنة من الأصفار
والواحدات التناسب الأسّي لفضاء حالة الـ qubit يُسمى التوازي
الكمي وهو مسؤول جزئياً عن ميزة الحواسيب الكمية على الكلاسيكية لكن الحاسوب
الكمي ليس مجرد معالج متوازٍ ضخم مجرد أن الـ qubit في الحاسوب الكمي يمكن أن تكون في
تراكب لعدد أسّي من الحالات لا يعني أننا نملك الوصول لكل المعلومات في كل من هذه
الحالات بما أن القياس يُنهار النظام إلى حالة واحدة أو أخرى لنرى
كيف يتجلى هذا في مسألة بسيطة لنقل أن هناك آلة يمكنك
إدخال بت واحد إليها ثم تطبق دالة ما على البت وتخرج بتاً واحداً آخر الآلة
داخل صندوق أسود لا نستطيع الوصول إليه كل ما يمكننا الوصول إليه هو البت
الذي ندخله x والبت الذي يخرجه الصندوق f
من x نريد معرفة ما هي الدالة f التي تطبقها الآلة
هناك أربع دوال ممكنة تأخذ بتاً واحداً إلى بت واحد آخر
فلمعرفة ما هي الدالة يمكننا ببساطة إدخال صفر ونرى إن أخرج صفراً أو واحداً ثم ندخل
واحداً ونفعل نفس الشيء كل من هاتين الخطوتين تُسمى استعلاماً هذه
إحدى طرق مقارنة الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية والكمية عبر ما يُسمى نموذج الاستعلام حيث نقارن عدد
الاستعلامات التي تحتاجها كل خوارزمية للصندوق الأسود لحل المسألة ففي هذه الحالة
طريقتنا الكلاسيكية احتاجت استعلامين للصندوق لمعرفة الدالة لنرى هل نستطيع أن نفعل أفضل إذا جعلنا حاسوباً
كمياً يستعلم الصندوق الأسود بدلاً من إدخال صفر أولاً ثم واحد الحاسوب
الكمي يستطيع إدخال qubit في تراكب من الصفر و
الواحد إلى الصندوق ففعلياً ندخل كلا المدخلين باستعلام واحد عندها
هل يعني ذلك أننا نستطيع معرفة الدالة باستعلام واحد فقط
للأسف ليس هذا هو الحال نرى لماذا تفشل هذه الفكرة عندما نختبرها على حاسوب كمي سنصنع
circuit من qubit اثنين الـ qubit صفر الممثل هنا بهذا الخط العلوي سيكون حالة الإدخال X التي ندخلها إلى
الصندوق الأسود الموضح هنا بالـ gate الكستنائية المسماة UF الـ gate UF
مصممة لأخذ qubit صفر كحالة الإدخال x ثم تطبيق تحويل على qubit واحد يأخذ
حالة الصفر إلى حالة f من x فطالما أن qubit 1 بدأ في حالة
الصفر فالمخرج هو x على qubit 0 و f من x على qubit 1 فلإيجاد f من x لكل من
x=0 و x=1 في آنٍ واحد يمكننا محاولة وضع qubit 0 في تراكب من 0 و1 قبل
إدخاله للصندوق الأسود يتم ذلك بـ gate Hadamard الحمراء هذه التي تحول حالة الصفر إلى 1/جذر2
ضرب 0 + 1 فبعد gate الصندوق الأسود يجب أن يكون لدينا الآن تراكب من كل من
f من 0 و f من 1 على qubit 1 عندما نقيس الـ qubit نأمل أن
نجيب على السؤال ما الدالة الموجودة داخل الصندوق الأسود لنستخدم Qiskit primitive sampler لتشغيل
الـ circuit وإرجاع النتيجة يمكننا اختيار عدد مرات تشغيل الـ circuit المسمى عينات بتغيير هذه
المعلمة المسماة shots هنا
هذا يكافئ عدد الاستعلامات التي نجريها للصندوق الأسود لنرى هل يكفي استعلام واحد
فقط إليكم النتيجة قسنا qubit 0 ليكون صفراً فهذه كانت
قيمة الإدخال x و qubit 1 ليكون واحداً وهي قيمة المخرج f من x فالآن
نعرف أن f من 0 يساوي 1 لكن ماذا عن f من 1 هنا تكمن المشكلة بمجرد
أن قسنا الحالة انهارت التراكبات ولم نحصل إلا على قياس جزء واحد من الدالة باستعلام
واحد هذا لا يخبرنا بكل ما نحتاج معرفته لتحديد أي دالة هي سنحتاج
استعلاماً ثانياً للصندوق لذلك فحتى لو أن مبدأ التوازي الكمي يسمح لنا بأن يُقيِّم
الصندوق الأسود f من 0 و f من 1 في آنٍ واحد فنحن لا نملك الوصول لكلتا
الإجابتين التوازي الكمي وحده لا يكفي خوارزمية Deutsch
تُظهر كيف يمكننا استخدام التوازي الكمي بطريقة مختلفة قليلاً لمعرفة شيء عن الدالة داخل الصندوق الأسود لن
نتمكن من معرفة الدالة بالضبط لكننا سنتمكن من معرفة شيء جديد عنها باستعلام
واحد لم نكن نستطيعه بحاسوب كلاسيكي لنبدأ بالنظر في جدول الدوال الأربع الممكنة
التي تأخذ بتاً واحداً إلى بت واحد آخر هنا يمكنكم رؤية أن اثنتين من الدوال f1 و f4 تعيدان دائماً
قيمة واحدة بغض النظر عن حالة الإدخال نسمي هاتين الدالتين
ثابتتين f2 و f3 ستعيدان إما صفراً أو واحداً حسب
حالة x نسمي هاتين الدالتين متوازنتين خوارزمية Deutsch
تحدد ما إذا كانت الدالة ثابتة أو متوازنة بإجراء بعض التعديلات الذكية على الـ circuit التي استخدمناها
من قبل إليكم الـ circuit تبدأ بتحضير qubit 0 في الحالة 1/جذر
2 ضرب 0 + 1 بـ Hadamard كما سبق و qubit 1 في الحالة 1/جذر2 ضرب 0 - 1
بـ gate NOT متبوعة بـ Hadamard
فالحالة الكاملة عند هذه النقطة هنا هي حيث هذه حالة qubit 0 و
هذه حالة qubit 1 تحضير qubit واحد بهذه الطريقة بدلاً من
تركه في حالة الصفر يمكّن الخوارزمية من استخدام التوازي الكمي بالتزامن مع التداخل لمعرفة
شيء عن دالة الصندوق الأسود لنرى كيف عندما يُدخل الـ qubit إلى UF gate الصندوق الأسود يمكن أن يحدث أمران
إذا كانت الدالة ثابتة فإن الصندوق الأسود سيجري عملية ما على qubit واحد وحده بغض النظر
عن حالة الصفر في هذه الحالة بما أن UF لا تمس qubit صفر أو
تهتم بحالته على الإطلاق فإن Hadamard الثاني هنا يلغي ببساطة ما
فعله Hadamard الأول وسنقيس الـ qubit في حالة الصفر لنلقِ نظرة على الدالة المتوازنة f2 كمثال لنرى
ماذا تفعل UF بالحالة في هذه الحالة عندما يكون x صفراً f من x تكون صفراً وعندما يكون x
واحداً f من x تكون واحداً تذكروا ما أخبرتكم عن gate الـ UF إنها تأخذ qubit 0
كحالة الإدخال x وتخرج f من x على qubit 1 بافتراض أن qubit 1
بدأ في حالة الصفر فلهذه الدالة ما تفعله UF بـ qubit 1 يعتمد
على qubit 0 إذا كان 0 صفراً فـ qubit 1 سيبقى في حالة الصفر للحصول على f
من x = 0 إذا كان qubit 0 واحداً فالصندوق الأسود سيطبق gate NOT على qubit 1 ويضعه
في حالة الواحد فنحصل على f من 1 يساوي 1 هذا بالضبط ما تفعله gate CNOT
gate الـ CNOT تأخذ qubit اثنين qubit تحكم و qubit هدف وتقلب
حالة qubit الهدف إذا كان qubit التحكم في حالة الواحد لكنها لا تفعل شيئاً للهدف إذا كان التحكم
في حالة الصفر فـ UF لـ f2 هي مجرد CNOT على Q0 و Q1 gate الـ
CNOT لن تفعل شيئاً للحد الأول بما أن qubit التحكم في حالة الصفر لكن في الحد الثاني
هذا الصفر ينقلب إلى واحد وهذا الواحد ينقلب إلى صفر وإذا أخرجنا إشارة سالبة سنرى أن حالة qubit 1
لم تتغير لكن هذا الحد اكتسب إشارة سالبة فحالة qubit 0 هي
التي تغيرت فعلاً انتقلت من 0 + 1 إلى 0 ناقص
1 عندما نطبق Hadamard الأخير على qubit 0 يحوله إلى حالة 1 فإذا كانت الدالة في الصندوق الأسود
هي f2 سنقيس واحداً بدلاً من صفر اتضح أن gate الـ UF للدالة المتوازنة الأخرى f3 هي
نفس gate الـ CNOT متبوعة بـ NOT على qubit 1 gate الـ NOT الأخيرة لا تؤثر على qubit صفر فعندما تكون الدالة
متوازنة سنقيس qubit 0 ليكون في حالة الواحد في نهاية الـ circuit الآن إذا لم تتابعوا كل
هذا فلا بأس أقترح أن تمروا عليه بأنفسكم لتروا كيف يعمل النقطة الرئيسية هنا هي ما
حدث عندما طبقنا CNOT للدالتين المتوازنتين qubit 0 استُخدم فقط كـ qubit تحكم لتغيير
حالة qubit 1 بديهياً قد تعتقدون أن qubit 0 سيبقى دون تغيير ومع ذلك بطريقة ما عملياتنا
على qubit واحد غيّرت فعلاً حالة qubit صفر بتغيير الطور النسبي بين جزئي
تراكبه هذه الظاهرة تُعرف بآلية ارتداد الطور وهي
غير بديهية للغاية مثل كثير من الظواهر الكمية بطريقة ما يمكنكم التفكير في آلية ارتداد الطور
مثل التجديف بقارب فعل دفع الماء للخلف يدفعك فعلاً للأمام تماماً كما أن العمليات على
qubit 1 تغير فعلاً qubit صفر الآن يمكننا تشغيل خوارزمية Deutsch على
Qiskit هنا يمكننا اختيار أي دالة نضعها داخل الصندوق الأسود واخترنا أن تكون f3 إليكم
مخطط circuit الخوارزمية ويمكننا تشغيلها كما سبق مع primitive الـ sampler سنضبط عدد
العينات إلى واحدة فقط ونرى ماذا نقيس في هذه الحالة قسنا واحداً
إذاً نعلم أن الدالة كانت متوازنة وهذا بالفعل ما توقعناه بما أن الصندوق الأسود احتوى على الدالة f3 فباستعلام واحد
فقط تمكنا من التمييز بين هاتين الفئتين من الدوال
كان هذا سيتطلب من خوارزمية كلاسيكية استعلامين لتحديده هذا يُظهر ميزة متواضعة للحوسبة
الكمية على الحوسبة الكلاسيكية وحدها لكنه ليس مبهراً جداً مجرد واحد مقابل اثنين لكن خوارزمية Deutsch
لا تزال مهمة للغاية في تاريخ الحوسبة الكمية لأنها قدمت الشرارة التي جعلت آخرين
يفكرون في خوارزميات كمية أكبر وأكثر تطوراً
وهذا يشمل توسيعاً متعدد الـ qubit لخوارزمية Deutsch يُظهر ميزة كمية أكثر إبهاراً بكثير
يُسمى خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa وهي تحل مسألة مشابهة لكن في هذه الحالة دالة الصندوق الأسود
التي نريد معرفتها تأخذ n بت كمدخل وتخرج بتاً واحداً كما
سبق نحن مُضمَنون أن الدالة إما ثابتة أي أن بت المخرج دائماً واحد أو دائماً صفر
بغض النظر عن سلسلة البتات المدخلة أو متوازنة أي أن المخرج صفر لنصف
سلاسل البتات المدخلة وواحد للنصف الآخر هناك طبعاً
دوال أخرى تأخذ n بت إلى بت واحد ليست ثابتة ولا متوازنة لكن في هذه المسألة نحن
مُضمَنون أن لا شيء من تلك الدوال داخل الصندوق الأسود الدالة في الصندوق مضمونة أن تكون إما ثابتة
أو متوازنة circuit الـ Deutsch-Jozsa تبدو مشابهة لخوارزمية Deutsch لكن مع qubit أكثر هنا لدينا
تنفيذ لخوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa لمعرفة دالة من ثلاثة بتات هذه المرة لدينا ثلاثة qubit
لحالة الإدخال بدلاً من واحد فقط ثم لدينا هذا الـ qubit الأخير لحالة المخرج كما سبق مرة أخرى
نحضّر جميع qubit الإدخال لتكون في حالة 0 + 1 و qubit المخرج
ليكون في حالة 0 - 1 ثم رغم أن الرياضيات أكثر تعقيداً في المتابعة المبدأ
يبقى نفسه إذا كانت الدالة ثابتة فلن تعتمد على الـ qubit الثلاثة العلوية إطلاقاً فحالاتها
ستتحول مرة أخرى إلى صفر بعد Hadamard الثانية وقياسنا سيعطي سلسلة من ثلاثة بتات كلها
أصفار لكن إذا كانت الدالة متوازنة فعندما نقيس الـ qubit بعد Hadamard فإن آلية ارتداد الطور
ستتسبب في أن يكون واحد أو أكثر من تلك البتات واحداً قد لا يكون من السهل رؤية ذلك هذه المرة لكن إذا عملتم
على كل خطوة بأنفسكم ستلاحظون أن هذا يجب أن يكون صحيحاً إحدى طرق التحقق هي محاولة حساب
احتمال قياس كل أصفار مع دالة متوازنة يجب أن تحصلوا على احتمال صفر لنشغل
خوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa على حاسوب كمي مع Qiskit الخطوة الأصعب ربما هي إنشاء دالة Deutsch-Jozsa
التي ستكون صندوقنا الأسود الذي نستعلمه هنا هذا الكود ينتج دالة Deutsch-Jozsa عشوائية
مضمونة أن تكون إما متوازنة أو ثابتة ثم نصنع circuit الـ Deutsch-Jozsa وندرج دالة الصندوق الأسود
هنا مرة أخرى نشغل الـ circuit مع sampler وبعد القياس ننظر إلى
البتات المقاسة لتحديد ما إذا كانت الدالة متوازنة أو ثابتة
إذا كانت كلها أصفار فهي ثابتة لكن إذا كان هناك بت واحد على الأقل في السلسلة فهي متوازنة في هذه
الحالة نحصل على سلسلة بتات 1 1 1
إذاً نعلم أن الدالة كانت متوازنة آمل أنني أعطيتكم لمحة أولى عن كيف يمكن للخوارزميات الكمية
أن تستفيد من ظواهر كمية مثيرة وغالباً دقيقة للحصول على ميزتها على الخوارزميات
الكلاسيكية ربما لاحظتم أيضاً كم يمكن أن يكون صعباً تصميم خوارزميات كمية حتى أول
واحدة تطلبت الكثير من الإبداع لتحقيق فوز متواضع فقط على الطرق الكلاسيكية ومنذ تلك الخوارزمية الأولى
استمر الفيزيائيون وعلماء الحاسوب في ابتكار طرق مبدعة بشكل لا يُصدق لاستخدام ميكانيكا الكم
لصالحهم بما في ذلك توسعات وتطبيقات إضافية لخوارزمية Deutsch-Jozsa إذا أردتم
التعرف على بعضها وكذلك تجربة خوارزميتي Deutsch و Deutsch-Jozsa بأنفسكم توجهوا إلى
الوحدة المرتبطة في الوصف للبدء شكراً للمشاهدة وأراكم في المرة القادمة